et avec nous pour ce club Béatrice
Houchard bonjour Béatrice d'être avec
nous journaliste grande spécialiste du
Tour de France auteur de ce livre le
Tour de France et la France du Tour et
Laurent gallinon bonjour merci d'être là
ravie de vous écrire dans ce club
journaliste aussi réalisateur auteur de
classique lieu de culte et champion
Meetic Mathias est revenue avec nous
vous l'avez compris on va parler du Tour
de France les coureurs sont dans les
Pyrénées Emmanuel Macron aussi le
président de la République suivra
l'étape du jour alors quel lien entre le
tour et les politiques vous nous le
direz et puis le tour c'est aussi en
lien fort bien sûr avec les territoires
qu'elle coup qu'elle bénéfice pour les
collectivités qui voient passer le tour
et on vous emmènera à Pau candidate
permanente pour accueillir le tour vous
verrez tout ça on va tout de suite pour
commencer sur les thèmes du jour
et on retrouve notre maillot jaune à
nous bonjour Jonathan du priez merci
d'être avec nous Jonathan vous suivez
pour deux étapes
[Rires]
qui
promet du spectacle
et oui c'est sûr Oriane ici on s'attend
à du spectacle entre Tarbes et cotress
en 45 km d'une étape qui va être
haltente et ici ont donc on se trouve à
capvernes-les-bains vous allez le voir
sur ces images d'Adrien pain juste
derrière moi c'est en train de s'animer
gentiment en centre-ville voilà il y a
un petit marché qui s'est qui s'est
monté avec des artistes locaux et puis
vous allez me suivre et juste derrière
moi il commence à y avoir un balai
incessant de voiture et de camping-car
parce qu'en fait on se trouve à côté de
la côte que vont emprunter les coureurs
au 30e kilomètre ce sera vers 14h 14h10
environ suivant la vitesse des coureurs
et c'est une côte qui est quand même pas
si simple même si évidemment tous les
regards du jour vont se tourner sur les
deux monuments que les coureurs vont
escalader le col d'Aspa et surtout le
mythique Tourmalet le Tourmalet je vous
rappelle c'est quand même un col hors
catégorie qui fait 17 km 7,5% de pente
moyenne c'est l'un des géants de
l'histoire du Tour l'un des plus
empruntés qui culmine à 2115 mètres
d'altitude et d'ailleurs le dernier
vainqueur au sommet bien c'était
Thibault Pinot que les Français
connaissent bien et apprécient et
aujourd'hui et bien ça promet aussi une
explication entre les deux favoris le
danoises Wingard et le sloven tadei
pogacchar qui a pris un petit coup hier
sur la tête
évidemment alors très attendu lui aussi
sur la route du Tour c'est le chef de
l'État Emmanuel Macron
oui Oriane Emmanuel Macron c'est pas
tout à fait un hasard s'il vient dans la
région on sait que le chef de l'État a
des a des racines familialissime et puis
c'est une tradition pour lead depuis
2017 de venir en tant que président
alors il va rejoindre tout à l'heure le
président le directeur pardon du Tour de
France Christian Prud'homme dans son
véhicule pour suivre les deux ascensions
dont je parlais le col d'Espagne et le
col du Tourmalet mais Emmanuel Macron ce
matin en ce moment au moment où je vous
parle il est en fait avec des élus
locaux dans la ville de Pau l'Élysée
nous nous disait que c'était pas
seulement une séquence sportive à
laquelle elle est à donner le président
mais en fait il voulait prolonger ses
échanges qu'il avait eu avec les maires
c'était mardi après les émeutes que la
France vient de vient de connaître et
vous allez l'entendre hier on a
rencontré son allié toujours François
Bayrou qui est le maire de Pau et bien
lui pense que le président ça va lui
faire du bien de venir dans sa commune
comme un petit bol d'air écoutez il
était au micro d'Adrien Paillard
il est heureux dans le climat où nous
sommes de rencontrer une ville dont on
peut dire que pour l'essentiel elle va
bien
il y a ici quasiment zéro chômeur ou en
tout cas il y a plus d'offres d'emploi
que de demande d'emploi beaucoup plus
deux fois plus d'offres d'emploi que de
demande d'emploi avec à la fois des
industries des petits commerces de
l'agriculture
d'élaboratoires de recherche une
université et c'est donc une ville qui
est un joyau qu'il connaît bien qu'il
aime bien et dans les temps qui courent
c'est pas si fréquent une ville dans
laquelle on a le on a le bonheur d'être
voilà et voilà et donc c'est devenu elle
sera scrutée de très près ici évidemment
dans ce contexte de tension mais il faut
aussi dire Oriane que venir sur le Tour
de France quand on est un président de
la République et ben c'est un peu comme
une figure imposée tous l'ont fait
précédemment se souvient de Nicolas
Sarkozy François Hollande et bien
Emmanuel Macron nous dérangera pas à la
règle
merci Jonathan évidemment vous suivrez
cette étape on verra votre reportage
demain et puis on verra le votre
reportage à Pau que vous avez tourné
hier ce sera un tout petit peu plus tard
dans ce club belle étape Pyrénées
Jonathan on vous retrouve tout à l'heure
Béatrice Huchard le Tour de France
Jonathan disait c'est un passage obligé
pour le président de la République alors
obligé depuis Nicolas Sarkozy oui c'est
le premier qui en fait suit vraiment une
étape dans la voiture de directeur de la
course avant il y avait eu quelques
générales de Gaulle et c'était pointé
sur le bord de la route à
Colombey-les-Deux-Églises en 1960
c'était il y a très longtemps il s'est
dépassé quand même un truc historique ce
jour-là le Plotton c'était arrêté pour
le saluer ce qui est la seule fois que
le peloton s'est arrêté pour saluer un
grand personnage de la France et 1960 on
était encore quand même proche de de la
guerre donc c'était vraiment quelque
chose Georges Pompidou non Valéry
Giscard d'Estaing il est venu sur le
Tour de France mais après quand il était
plus président Jacques Chirac a
accueilli le tour en Corrèze pour faire
plaisir à sa femme et je crois qu'il dit
lui seul l'intéresse pas le passionnait
pas mais il faisait tellement bien
semblant que c'était formidable Sarkozy
est un alors pour le coup un vrai spéci
un vrai passionné de vélo François
Hollande aime le sport en général est-ce
qu'il est calé en cycliste je serais pas
vous dire et puis je crois que
maintenant ça fait partie de c'est
devenu de fait une figure une figure
imposée pour aller rencontrer le au-delà
des coureurs et de la course là les
électeurs de la population sur le bord
de la route Emmanuel Macron qui choisit
les Pyrénées évidemment il a un
attachement particulier avec cette
région donc en gagnant oui puisque quand
il était jeune il avait une il allait
faire du ski à La Mongie il a mangé
c'est dans le col du Tourmalet on vient
de parler Jonathan c'est le géant du
Tour de France c'est le premier col
emprunté par les coureurs du Tour de
France en 1910 donc il y a toute il y a
toute une symbolique et c'est vrai que
depuis trois quatre ans Emmanuel Macron
se rend régulièrement sur le l'étape des
Pyrénées qui passent dans dans la vallée
de son enfance
un intérêt politique pour les présidents
de la République à se rendre sur le Tour
de France est-ce que politiquement ça
rapporte quelque chose alors bien malin
qui pourrait dire si politiquement est
donc électoralement ça ça se traduit
d'une manière ou d'une autre c'est
difficile à c'est difficile à mesurer
après un président de la République un
homme politique qui voit toujours un
intérêt politique dans tout ce qu'il
dans tout ce qu'il fait j'imagine donc
aller à la rencontre des populations et
aller saluer un événement très populaire
ça n'est pas ça n'est pas neutre ça
n'empêche pas leur propre intérêt leur
propre passion après ce que c'est ce que
les gens vont voter pour un tel parce
qu'un tel est allé voir le Tour de
France j'espère que non ça ne ça suffit
pas quand même non il y a un intérêt ou
pas si folklore c'est si une évasion
dans son programme je pense qu'en ce
moment au milieu des tensions le Tour de
France n'a jamais porté aussi bien son
nom que une machine à rêve c'est ça la
force du Tour de France c'est c'est
l'abstraction totale moi je l'ai
découvert comme journaliste pendant
trois semaines il peut y avoir un
attentat c'était le cas d'ailleurs en
2016 à Nice vous passez complètement à
côté donc c'est une abstraction total en
fait
c'est une très très grande bulle et
l'implosse rarement donc là Emmanuel
Macron se faufile dans la bulle et puis
même pour lui je pense que ça va lui
changer les idées mais électoralement je
sais pas s'il y a un poids souvent le
président se fait huer dès qu'il passe
auprès des spectateurs donc oui bien sûr
voilà et puis il reçoit ils peuvent
recevoir des poches de voilà d'urine des
choses comme ça donc enfin c'est pas
vraiment
c'est plus à risque que c'est une bulle
et c'est aussi vous le disiez un
événement populaire et dans la période
actuelle est-ce que c'est aussi un moyen
peut-être pour les Français s'évader
c'est le plus grand événement populaire
gratuit on le rappelle tout le monde
peut aller sur les routes en bas de chez
soi un peu plus loin pour aller regarder
les coureurs oui alors j'ai je pense
souvent à ce que m'avait dit Christian
Prudhomme le directeur du Tour il y a
deux ou trois ans au moment des gilets
jaunes alors sans faire de liens voilà
ce serait très très imprudent et très
prétentieux de faire quelques liens que
ce soit mais en disant que depuis
quelques années quand il allait
repérer les mieux pour choisir les
villes étapes quand il a l'air les
petites communes de plus en plus on lui
disait c'est formidable parce que on a
plus enfin vous connaissez le refrain on
a plus le il y a plus d'écoles il y a
plus de commerce il y a plus de
pharmacie il y a plus mais le Tour de
France ne nous oublie pas comme si
c'était alors non pas le dernier il faut
pas exagérer mais dans certains coins le
Tour de France ne les oublie pas et le
jour de l'année où il se passe quelque
chose c'est quand le Tour de France pas
forcément s'arrête d'ailleurs mais passe
dans la commune même quand le tour passe
dans une dans une commune très vite si
c'est une étape de plat 30 secondes et
tout le monde est passé c'est quand même
un essai quand même un événement et le
le lien entre le entre le tour et les
populations et les territoires comme on
dit maintenant et vraiment très
important
pour les collectivités mais l'intérêt
pour les français pour les habitants qui
peuvent se tournent c'est la tradition
du cirque en fait vous avez beau habiter
dans une vallée du Cantal le Tour de
France passe chez vous soudain votre
village existe moi je me souviens de de
des tables du Tour de France qui partait
de village de de 800 habitants c'est le
Paris Christian prud'hommes son
prédécesseur Jean-Marie Leblanc avait
une toute autre politique mais
aujourd'hui avec la difficulté d'arriver
dans les centres-villes
accéder au centre-ville on fait souvent
des des arrivées donc on va dire en zone
zone périurbaine et souvent les départs
maintenant c'est aussi le Paris qui sont
prior c'est de passer par la diagonale
du vide ce qu'on appelle la géographie
la diagonale du vide donc on les inne
pas sur les départements secondaires et
on va chercher voilà des villes des
villages un petit peu oubliés et je
trouve que c'est vraiment en cela le
tour de la France en France souvent on
reproche souvent autour de France de ne
plus faire le tour de l'Hexagone le tour
de la France c'est aussi passé en fait
d'une banlieue à une préfecture à une
sous-préfecture et une vallée un peu
oubliée et un village perché et d'aller
partout ce qu'on ne peut pas faire si on
si on continue si on fait le tour de la
France stricto
il y a quand même des régions qui sont
plus privilégiés que d'autres ah bah les
Alpes et les Pyrénées sont
incontournables tous les ans et puis de
temps en temps un peu de Massif Central
on retrouve le Puy on retrouvera le
Puy-de-Dôme dans l'étape de dimanche un
peu de Jura un peu de veau je vois là
c'est un équilibre savant mais il y a
toujours ce passage obligé dans les
Alpes et dans les Pyrénées bien sûr pour
l'intérêt de la course il y a évidemment
l'intérêt de la course mais vous le
disiez Christian Prudhomme nous le
disait il était notre invité il y a
quelques jours qui s'attache évidemment
sur plusieurs années parce qu'il peut
pas le faire en une seule édition mais à
répartir un petit peu le passage du Tour
de France sur le tout le territoire
Laurent Alino c'est aussi un moyen vous
nous disiez un peu tout à l'heure pour
ces Français qui se sentent peut-être
parfois oublié relégués et bien de voir
leur communale à la télé et d'avoir le
sentiment de voir qu'on parle d'eux tout
simplement le mode 8 ne couille soudain
il y a une revanche en fait sur le un
contexte économique social
je me souviens là encore de d'expérience
ou on fait un fond entre guillemets des
Vosges on avait une population qui
remercie vraiment qui disait enfin le
Tour de France passe chez nous enfin on
existe le passage du Tour de France dans
une commune dans une sous-préfecture
c'est un bol d'air mais il faut imaginer
qu'il y a des départements qui sont qui
ont été oubliés pendant 20-30 ans
l'arrivée l'année dernière à Longwy qui
est une cité une ancienne cité minière
avec une grande communauté italienne
enfin d'or italienne soudain cette ville
qui est là au confins on va dire de la
France sidérurgique un petit peu oubliée
et maltraitée soudain la fête apparaît
et là effectivement il y a une sorte de
c'est pas une revanche mais il y a une
comment dire oui il y a un rêve et c'est
ça le Tour de France c'est une machine à
rêve en fait c'est toujours frappant de
voir quand on est alors pour le coup sur
le bord de la route
même si le Tour de France ne s'arrête
pas le tour passe les gens ont attendu
trois heures avec le pique-nique les
casquettes il fait chaud etc ils n'ont
pas à peine reconnu les coureurs à part
le maillot jaune parce qu'entre les
casques et les lunettes c'est quand même
devenu très difficile de reconnaître
Thibaut Pinot à la Philippe ou Mathieu
van der Poel le tour passe et on replie
le le le comment dire le client on
reprend la on reprend les affaires les
gens sont les gens sont heureux le tour
est venu chez eux et ça alors ça paraît
un peu ça pourrait paraître dérisoire et
c'est quelque chose d'énorme au
contraire et dans un contexte où tout
passe par le numérique ce qui est aussi
un facteur de séparation des générations
tout le monde a accès à la route sans QR
code sans portique de sécurité sans
fouille c'est très très important ce qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui une personne de 70
ans ne se dit pas je dois aller sur
internet pour prendre un ticket c'est
c'est c'est aussi une source de de on va
dire de respiration tout est tout est
beaucoup plus simple
et on va retourner dans les
Hautes-Pyrénées puisque c'est là qu'a
lieu l'étape du jour on va aller avec le
président du conseil et le départemental
de des Hautes-Pyrénées bonjour Michel
Pélieu merci beaucoup d'être avec
il y a quelques instants de la venue
d'Emmanuel Macron aujourd'hui sur cette
étape c'est une fierté pour vous de
recevoir le président de la République
dans votre département
c'est peut-être une habitude parce que
c'est quasiment tous les ans donc on
l'accueille toujours avec plaisir bien
sûr comme on a créé le président de la
République malgré tout bon il a des
attaches d'un ce département il y a
passé une partie de sa jeunesse donc il
irait bien toujours avec plaisir bon
c'est un moment de rencontre sur un
moment de convivialité voilà et après
bon il y a toutes l'aspect sportif en
même temps
et puis à l'importance l'importance pour
le président du Département que vous
êtes du passage du Tour dans votre
département qu'est-ce que ça apporte un
département comme le vôtre de voir
passer le tour
quand même qu'après Paris les
Hautes-Pyrénées sont le département le
plus traversé le Tour de France et tous
les hommes dans les dans les
Hautes-Pyrénées
il y a quelques minutes le Tourmalet le
tour est passé plus de 80 fois au
tourballé 84 fois je crois sur 110 donc
bon ben c'est une c'est une
médiatisation des paysages bon faut pas
il faut quand même rappeler que le
beaucoup d'images beaucoup de d'images
télévisions il y a plus de de plusieurs
milliards de téléspectateurs
le tour est diffusé dans 190 pays et
dans le 160 pays en direct
donc ça permet de véhiculer des images
de des paysages et de rendre aussi de
donner au département une certaine
attractivité on s'aperçoit quand même de
chaque fois que le Tour de France est
par là bon il y a un afflux de touristes
et pour un département dont l'activité
touristique génère plus d'un tiers des
revenus je crois que c'est hyper
important
ça veut dire que ça rapporte plus un
département comme le vote ce que ce que
ça vous coûte parce que ça a quand même
un coup d'être meilleur le Tour de
France
en récupère au moins de 10 euros dans
l'économie du territoire
on suivra évidemment ces belles images
du département des Hautes-Pyrénées
aujourd'hui dans l'étape du jour merci
Michel Pélieu d'avoir été avec nous et
Bonne Étape aujourd'hui du côté de chez
vous on le voit l'importance pour pour
les départements on leur organisme
d'accueillir le Tour de France et
l'autre Pyrénées c'est très traversé le
rappeler le président du Département oui
le massif des Pyrénées fait partie de la
narration épique du Tour de France
depuis 1910 donc évidemment chaque
édition se dénoue on va dire dans dans
ce massif en partie ce qui est
intéressant de voir c'est que l'école du
Tour de France sont devenus des pôles
d'attractivité touristique c'est-à-dire
que aujourd'hui vous avez des gens qui
courent cyclistes qui traversent avec
leur famille la France pour tout
simplement faire le Tourmalet le col
d'Aspar
ou le col d'aubisk il amène le coercice
un groupe d'amis soit une famille
ça rapporte en fait donc c'est du
logement enfin c'est de l'hébergement
c'est du c'est des dépenses dans les
restaurants et c'est colle moi je les
pratiques en tant que cycliste autour
des Pyrénées depuis l'âge de de 15 ans
et j'ai bien vu l'évolution c'est-à-dire
que autour de moi depuis 5-6 ans
j'entends parler anglais italien
allemand souvent on a j'ai déjà monté un
col à côté d'un brésilien qui rêvé de
faire le tour malais donc vous voyez à
quel point c'est lieu de culte en fait
véhicule avec eux donc toute une une
richesse on va aller dans une ville qui
vit une véritable histoire d'amour avec
le Tour de France c'est la vôtre Laurent
Galli non c'est Pau au pied des Pyrénées
elle était ville de départ de l'étape
d'hier Jonathan du prière et Adrien pain
nous emmène dans les coulisses du
village départ
du Tour de France à Nîmes place de
Verdun à Pau c'est l'influence des
grands jours et pour Josie Puerto c'est
tourné de bises obligatoires bonjour
ça va toi chérie
Josy Puerto et depuis 40 ans la madame
Tour de France de Pau c'est unique dans
le pays le chef-lieu du Béarn dispose
d'une élue préposée autour de France à
l'année alors au village départ Josie
est comme un poisson dans l'eau au
milieu des quidams des élus et des
officiels
[Musique]
1983 je suis délégué autour de France et
donc vous allez à mon bureau il y a
écrit délégué et François Bayrou quand
il est arrivé il me dit tu es évidemment
délégué autour de France et ça me ça me
suit et j'en suis très très fier même
les têtes du peloton professionnel ont
tous un souvenir avec elle Cédric
Vasseur manager de l'équipe française
Cofidis n'échappe pas à la règle alors
on a une histoire qui remonte à quelques
années l'équipe gagne avait l'habitude
de venir en stage à Pau et donc chaque
année on était on était reçu en mairie
de Pau et c'est comme ça qu'il fait
connaissance de Josy au total Pau a
accueilli 74 fois la grande boucle et
ces dernières années les liens semblent
encore se resserrer pas tout à fait le
hasard Josie cultive une relation très
étroite avec le patron du Tour Christian
Prudhomme
on a une vraie histoire d'amour et quel
que soit le il y a eu Félix c'est
évident mais il y a eu aussi évidemment
Jean-Marie Leblanc avec que je continue
à voir qui est toujours maintenant il y
a Christian Prudhomme voilà ce sont des
hommes avec un avec un cœur une
générosité extraordinaire
et l'organisateur de la course à Esso le
lui rend bien d'abord pour des
considérations sportives mais aussi
logistiques Paul loge dans ses hôtels
5000 personnes de l'organisation pendant
3 nuits des capacités qui en font une
candidate d'office chaque année que pour
est-il également situé bien évidemment
au pied des Pyrénées donc soit on va
vers le massif montagneux soit en un
sort ensuite parce qu'il y a tous les
bergement ce qui est absolument
essentiel que peau est très facile
d'accès notamment par l'autoroute c'est
à dire que c'est la logistique est
importante aussi pour l'émergement des
cours à l'hébergement précisément il se
fait essentiellement dans la ville de
Pau pour cette édition la commune a
cassé sa tirelire et dépenser 300.000
euros pour être village des parts et
accueillir le Tour de France féminin fin
juillet
la somme peut paraître conséquente mais
à Esso considère qu'un euro investi par
une collectivité rapporte 3 à 7 fois la
mise pour les élus cette dépense n'en
est donc pas vraiment une
retombées assurer sur des budgets de la
promotion de nos territoires ça
coûterait avant beaucoup plus cher pour
et le tour c'est surtout ce lien direct
des Palois avec leur star comme Matthieu
ladanius un coureur professionnel de
l'équipe Groupama FDJ venu saluer son
public
en France et même dans le monde c'est
important et dans les paddocks la foule
est venue en masse pour venir apprécier
l'ambiance auprès des coureurs du Tour
de France est extraordinaire et il faut
que ça dure
le temps passé le jour passe à la fois
que franchement ça ferait un manque de
plat donc j'espère que ça continue
au corps espère dépasser à terme les
villes de Bordeaux et de Paris à ce jour
les villes les plus traversées par la
Grande Boucle
et Laurent gallinon vous êtes de
posséder une véritable histoire d'amour
à on le voit entre pot et le Tour de
France oui oui de toute façon c'est il y
a une fusion
référente à une élue référente à l'année
autour de France
oui c'est un grand personnage historique
du cyclisme et puis dans la ville locale
paloise c'est une femme qui a fait
beaucoup pour tisser un le lien enfin
pour en tout cas entretenir le lien
entre le Tour de France et la ville de
Pau je pense qu'on peut dire que le Tour
de France passe quasiment chaque année à
Pau depuis maintenant une trentaine
d'années c'est une ville qui est très
bien sué comme la décrit sur prud'hommes
donc au pied des Pyrénées et qui a
évidemment toute la toute l'offre en
termes d'hôtellerie pour loger le tout
ce cirque qu'il Tour de France pour
ville traversée vous avez le podium vous
Béatrice
puisque jusqu'à nouvel ordre
c'est-à-dire jusqu'à 2024 Paris a
toujours été ville arrivée longtemps
ville de départ dans les premières
années et villes d'arrivée il y aura une
exception l'année prochaine puisqu'en
raison des Jeux Olympiques le tour
arrivera à Nice et après tout pourquoi
elle tourne arriverait-il pas ailleurs
qu'à Paris c'est très bien aussi
Bordeaux ensuite avec 81 passage je
crois et puis Pau je sais plus si c'est
74 disait leur portage moi j'ai 71 75
ans
et on va voir parce que évidemment être
candidat c'est un coup pour les
collectivités Mathias on va voir tout ça
avec vous il y a un volet financier
quand on veut être collectivité
traversée par le tour absolument il y a
sans surprise il y a un ticket d'entrée
dont doivent s'acquitter les villes aux
collectivités qui souhaiteraient voir la
Grande Boucle passer sur leur terre
alors une journée de repos ça coûte 60
000 euros une ville départ 80 000
l'arrivée d'une étape c'est 120000 euros
des montants qui sont évidemment
cumulables exemple une ville arrivée qui
accueillerait une journée de repos puis
un départ devrait débourser pas moins de
260 000 euros et ce n'est pas tout ça ce
sont les frais de base auxquels il faut
évidemment ajouter d'éventuelles
aménagements types rond-point travaux de
chaussée mais aussi l'animation la
communication et enfin l'organisation
logistique donc le travail des agents
municipaux pour installer les barrières
par exemple au total cela peut parfois
faire doubler voire triplés l'assiette
budgétaire un coup que par exemple ne
sont plus près assumer pour diverses
raisons politiques des élus comme
Grégory Doucet maire de Lyon le
Grenoblois
Eric Piol ou encore la rainez Nathalie
appairer alors ça peut représenter des
grosses sommes mais il y a aussi des
retombées quand on accueille de toi oui
on le voyait tout à l'heure les
retombées sont même indéniables pour les
villes étapes les hôtels font le plein
même chose pour les commerces on estime
qu'un spectateurs des bourses en moyenne
2 euros dans un commerce local avec
environ 500 000 spectateurs sur chaque
étape le calcul et rapide ce qui est
aussi souvent mis en avant notamment par
l'organisateur ce sont les retombées
médiatiques pour la reconnaissance à
l'internationale du territoire de ces
produits la course est suivie dans plus
de 160 pays en direct regarder par 2,5
milliards de téléspectateurs avec un
dispositif audiovisuel qui met
évidemment en valeur les paysages en
2013 l'accord savait réalisé une étude
quantitative sur les retombées du tour
sur ces terres résultat en ayant mis sur
la table cette année-là 7,7 millions
d'euros l'île de Beauté estime en avoir
récupéré pas moins de 17,9 millions soit
plus du double effectivement c'est une
bonne affaire d'accueillir le Tour de
France il y a des villes ou des lieux
qui doivent leur notoriété autour de
France alors j'en ai deux en tête le
Orcier Merlette qui était pas très connu
en 1971 quand Louis socania dans une
étape célèbre inflige un retard de plus
de 8 minutes à Eddy Merck ça n'était pas
rien personne ne battait Eddy Merckx à
l'époque l'année suivante il y a eu un
monde fou au sport d'hiver à à Orcier
merlette et puis l'autre exemple
puisqu'on est sur Public Sénat il faut
le citer c'est le Futuroscope la
première fois que le tour est venu sur
le Futuroscope il y avait que des grues
et un chantier et René Monory qui était
Président du Sénat et président du
conseil départemental de la de la Vienne
à l'époque à utiliser en plus c'était un
vrai passionné aussi a vraiment utilisé
le Tour de France qui est venu cinq six
fois et la notoriété du Futuroscope sur
le plan international c'est le tour de
France qu'il a lui a qui le lui a donné
donc c'est jackpot pour certains
collectivités Laurent gagné non
d'accueillir le tour oui c'est le
jackpot c'est surtout en terme d'image
je pense
j'employer un mot un peu un peu grossier
mais vous pouvez faire un grassure de
France
élaborer une sorte de lifting autour de
votre commune ou de votre région qui est
sinistrée par une image médiatique
péjorative ou par l'effet divers
je pense à l'aise de la France notamment
il y a aussi quelque chose un aspect
avec Christian Prudhomme qui est qui est
nouveau c'est la mise en valeur des du
tourisme de mémoire c'est à dire que
avant quand passer autour de Verdun ou
même dans le Nord autour de Notre-Dame
de Lorette par exemple bon il y avait
des plans d'hélicoptère et puis c'est
s'arrêter là aujourd'hui il y a des
étapes qui sont thématisées
autour de thèmes d'anniversaire par jour
de 14-18 on a vu ça pendant les
commémorations ce qui permet de mettre
en valeur des territoires un petit peu à
la géographie à l'histoire un petit peu
un petit peu flou vous voyez et donc
cette thématisation des étapes permet de
d'asseoir une identité pour des régions
en mal on va dire de d'image d'image
positives c'est évidemment quand on est
sur une station balnéaire de la Côte
d'Azur c'est plus facile de faire de la
belle image que quand on est sur un
champ de blé
dans dans la mode absolument d'un point
de vue objectif mais voilà c'est il y a
une narration qui en surimpression de de
du récit sportif il y a aussi une
narration qui évolue par par la société
ASO pour mettre en valeur des
territoires toujours un petit peu on va
dire endommagé par par l'histoire
économique sociale et parfois l'histoire
aussi militaire il y a beaucoup de
collectivités qui veulent accueillir le
tour Christian prud'hommes nous le
disait il y a beaucoup plus de dossiers
évidemment que deux possibilités d'être
villes de départ ou d'arriver mais il y
a aussi Mathias le rappelait certains
maires qui ne veulent plus accueillir le
Tour de France pour diverses raisons oui
avec quelques changements de pied
parfois puisque par exemple Grenoble la
bouder quand pendant quelques années et
maintenant ce serait beaucoup plus voilà
voilà plus alors pour pour que le tour
revienne Bordeaux qui a aussi un maire
écolo le Tour de France il passe cette
année donc bon après c'est le c'est leur
droit aussi où il y a Rennes qui a l'air
très très antique puisque quand le tour
est parti de Bretagne après le après le
covidité entre l'écologie et le Tour de
France elle se pose déjà alors je sais
qu'il y a pas mal de de d'efforts parce
que par exemple toutes les voitures de
l'organisation maintenant sont soit
électriques soit hybride il y a beaucoup
il y a eu beaucoup de ménages c'est le
mot qui convient qui a été fait pour que
les coureurs ne jettent pas les les
bidons ou les les musettes de
ravitaillement n'importe où donc
maintenant il y a des zones il y a des
zones précises pour pour éviter de
laisser des dégâts derrière cela dit
l'organisation du Tour faite etc qui a
des dégâts derrière c'est c'est une faut
dire aussi que c'est une organisation
phénoménale le Tour de France et un des
un des événements les mieux organisés de
de France sûrement du monde je ne sais
pas donc oui la question elle se pose
elle se pose forcément les hélicoptères
les voitures oui il y a forcément cette
mais la réflexion est en cours après ça
donnera pas peut-être pas satisfaction à
tout le monde mais on va quand même pas
supprimer le Tour de France si des gens
va perdre la planète on va au moins
garder le tour des fois eux-mêmes
commencent à sauver la question qui est
déjà démarré on va dire par ces
recherches c'est un docteur en
philosophie en plus d'être encore
cycliste à soulever au début du Tour de
France c'est ces questions autour de
l'impact écologique du Tour de France
mais il est encore un bel avenir on va
terminer là-dessus le Tour de France a
un bel avenir bien sûr le Tour de France
a un bel avenir c'est reste un sport
anachronique et je pense que dans une
société un petit peu on va dire enfin
dans un sport très marketé aujourd'hui
le cyclisme est encore un refuge pour
l'inattendu je parle de la narration
sportive la chute la défaillance il y a
en tout est encore possible sur sur le
Tour de France et on va dire qu'il y a
encore un aspect familial je parlais
d'un cirque c'est un barnum mais c'est
aussi un cirque et je pense que ça ça
doit être préservé on verra qui prendra
la suite de Christian Prudhomme mais
tant que Christian Prudhomme est entre
guillemets au manège voilà il y aura
cette ce côté ce patrimoine qui sera qui
sera conservé tel quel et sur la route
du Tour tout le monde a toujours le
sourire et ça ça n'est pas partout
notamment en ce moment et ça fait
plaisir par les temps ça fait plaisir et
on suivra bien sûr ce Tour de France
mais on va parler de la revue de presse
il y a pas de Tour de France aujourd'hui
je crois Mathias mais on va voir le
reste de l'actualité
[Musique]
et Mathias malgré plusieurs jours
d'alcalmie les émeutes sont toujours à
la une de la presse régionale carreleur
descompte est arrivé comme le titre La
Dépêche du Midi le journal toulousain
parle d'un balai de suspect à la barre
des tribunaux Ouest-France qui a assisté
à plusieurs comparutions immédiates ces
derniers jours par le de profil de
récits et de justification très variées
chez les émeutiers présentés
pour les juges enfin le quotidien
L'Alsace met à ça une le témoignage de
mère de famille de sa région pointée du
doigt depuis le début des émeutes les
parents disent se battre pour offrir un
avenir meilleur à leurs enfants malgré
les difficultés l'année dernière un vote
décisif à l'Assemblée de Corse Mathias
oui ce matin fait état de débat
difficile entre les différents groupes
nationalistes de l'île de Beauté
finalement la délibération en faveur
d'un statut d'autonomie de la Corse a
été adopté peu avant minuit cet accord
est présenté comme majeur dans la marche
de l'île vers un nouveau statut
institutionnel disent les élus
insulaires qui espèrent dorénavant une
déclaration du Président de la
République le 14 juillet le courrier de
l'Est revient sur matin sur les risques
d'incendie sommes-nous prêts s'interroge
le journal angevin l'été dernier
d'importance incendies ont ravagé plus
de 1500 hectares dans le Maine-et-Loire
et notamment la forêt de Baugé le
Courrier de l'Ouest annonce donc le
déploiement cette année d'un plan
départemental contre les feux travaux
préparatoires plan d’intervention des
secours le journal note par ailleurs que
la mise en place de la vidéo détection
d'éventuelles départs de feu ne se fera
pas cette année sur leur territoire on
termine par la saison festival c'est
parti Oriane les amoureux de culture
doivent déjà se frotter les mains la
Provence mais elle a une le Festival
d'Avignon qui a donc levé son rideau
hier le journal titre que la fête
commence pour la 77e édition du plus
grand festival de théâtre au monde un
peu plus au sud de l'indépendant de
Perpignan nous parle du festival Les
Déferlantes qui aura lieu cette année à
Barcarès et qui annonce cette année
encore une belle programmation enfin la
Nouvelle République met à sa une terre
du son le festival du sud-touranjo avec
à l'affiche entre autres Orelsan a des
Lomepal ou la femme merci Mathias pensez
être vu des festivals merci
pour cette
revue avec nous on revoit votre livre
classique lieu de culte et champion
mythique il s'affiche voilà et on
regarde le livre de Béatrice Hochard le
Tour de France et la France du Tour
merci à tous les deux d'avoir été avec
nous pour nous parler de ce Tour de
France merci à tous de nous avoir suivis
pour voir ou revoir cette émission c'est
sur publicena.fr à 18h vous avez
rendez-vous avec Thomas Hut pour
sciences publiques et non on se retrouve
demain très bonne journée
[Musique]